what was the nature of their opposition
to
totalitarianism is it basically
freedom well the value of freedom so
let's go through the three of them so
emma goldman she was an
early anarchist figure you know we'll
talk about her later i'm sure
she got deported from the united states
with her partner in crime
alexander berkman literal crime he tried
to assassinate uh
frick who was andrew carnegie's main man
in the pittsburgh steel mill strike
um she got deported to the soviet union
and they're like they're like oh you
want socialism because at the time the
anarchists were regarded as socialist
you know go choke on it and she's there
and she was watching in great horror
uh what was going on and she actually
went to lenin's office and she goes this
isn't what we're about the revolution is
about
the individual and free speech and
everyone working together to further a
society
and he told her that you know you know
free speech is a bourgeois contrivance
and regardless you can't have these
circumstances in the midst of a
revolution
and when she left the soviet union and
you know she went to britain and at the
time
before the 1917 there was a lot of
discussion among
socialist circles about what would the
revolution look like right would there
be the bakunin anarchist model would
there be the marxist model
obviously the bolsheviks ended up
winning but even then it wasn't obvious
because there was the bolsheviks and the
mensheviks and
what people you know you and i know what
those words mean but
bolsheviks were kind of funny because
boisha means bigger and mancha means
smaller
the mensheviks had the numbers it was
sarcastic that they were called
mensheviks and the bolsheviks were
called bolshah and lenin you know
destroyed all his foes
in a very merciless way obviously
beforehand
you know there was the idea like okay
with all these cockamamie ideas
we have to work together you know we
don't know what's going to look like for
the cause then as soon as he sees power
he's like yeah yeah we're not doing that
kind of pluralism anymore
this is going to be the right approach
so she left the soviet union as did
berkman
she wrote a book that they titled my
dissolution with russia
and i remember this one anecdote which
i'm going to discuss in the forthcoming
book
where she goes to britain and the
british were very red at the time they
really
had something called the fabian society
which was the predecessor to the british
labour party
which were like all right we're going to
get rid of liberalism and have a
socialist
kind of nation and she gave talks and
there was this one
time where she gave a talk and she
started and there was a standing ovation
by the time she was done you could hear
a pin drop
because she dared to look at these
people in the face something they'd be
fighting for all their lives and saying
you know we've been to the future and it
works
and she's like guys this is worse than
the czar uh you know people are under
house arrest you're not allowed to have
you know newspapers are being shut down
if they have heretical views so on and
so forth
and you know she was just even more of a
pariah than she had been previously so
she is you know deserves huge accolades
in that regard i brought her up and we
were talking about
with our conversation with iran orwell i
think
you don't need me to explain what he has
done and continues to do
to use fiction to demonstrate the
horrors
of a totalitarian state
you